will you see the next movie with Ben  Affleck as Batman you know I'm happy for  Ben but I don't know how that's gonna  work  Morgan Freeman played Lucius Fox in the  Dark Knight trilogy but he doesn't sound  very interested in the upcoming Batman  vs Superman with Ben Affleck why do you  think that well because the Dark Knight  was almost it pretty much it did you see  Batman Begins yes I don't think you can  beat that saying no one will ever be  there I very much liked him  but former Batman himself Christian Bale  is team Affleck everyone brings their  own elements to it Fennell through that  as well  I think the trailers are looking great  I'm looking forward to that next Freeman  will become the vice president in the  action packed sequel London has fallen  out March 4th